l'atterrissage chaotique de fil à est
larguée par la sonde rosetta sur la
comète sourire 2014 a permis de révéler
des années plus tard des informations
surprenantes sur le caractère de la
glace à la surface de la comète
[Musique]
c'était en 2014 filahi le petit
atterrisseur s'apprête à se poser en
douceur sur la comète 67 p
surnommé djouhri me l'atterrissage ne
s'est pas vraiment passé comme prévu
un des problèmes c'est qu'est un au
moment du contact
il devait y avoir une bonbonne de gaz
qui planquaient fils aérosols et un
mécanisme dans le crash de réceptionner
et les deux n'ont pas marché faute de
son cri fils a abrité le bord d'une
falaise raser un ensemble de rochers
avant de s'écraser dans une position
inconfortable à l'ombre d'une falaise
bien le cacher à l'autre chose qui n'a
pas fait revenir la bactérie des scellés
chargé des fêtes de mesures phil ivey
sonder l'intérieur de la comète en
forant un trou c'était devenu impossible
les secrets de la glace sous la surface
devait rester un mystère
enfin c'est ce que tout le monde pensait
une chose que filets aux états la sonde
qui l'a larguée ont accompli avec brio
c'est la capture de photos de la comète
des milliers d'image que sonia
fornaciari sont étudiantes analyse en
détail pour caractériser la glace à la
surface de la comète
certaines images attire leur attention
des tâches pâle sur cette comète sombre
on a quand même vous savez le sombre cet
avis de réfléchir à peu près aussi aux
sondés l'avenir qui arrive quand vous
avez une tâche prions de la sas a parlé
tout de suite dans les images sans
savoir elle venait de découvrir le
deuxième site que fileyeurs et durant
son atterrissage située à 30 mètres de
sa position finale
un site que son collègue lawrence
o'rourke cherchait désespérément à
identifier puis un moment c'est deux
images m'ont frappé
c'est et inusitées on aurait dit de la
glace coupé comme si quelqu'un à l'aide
d'une scie il avait tranché si que
filahi en percutant la surface de la
comète a mis à nu une partie de cette
glace blanche vieille 2 milliards
d'années
tel un détective sur une scène de crime
lawrence auront qu à les faire parler
ses tâches
à défaut de pouvoir forer le sol de la
comète comme prévu il va prospecter les
données à l'aide de milliers de photos
il reconstitue un modèle 3d de la
surface de souris et des dernières
minutes du vol de fils hayes l'analyse
fine des multiples images montrent que
l'atterrisseur s'est enfoncé dans la
glace
un indice majeur dans la sphère new
quand on compresse la neige avec nos
pieds par exemple devient de plus en
plus compacts et dure le temps qu'on met
à la compresser donne un indice de sa
résistance à la compression
théoriquement on peut faire le même type
de calcul avec la glace de la comète
mais il ya un problème on ne sait pas
combien tu enfiles un ami pour
compresser ses 25 centimètres de glace
la réponse est venue d'où on ne
l'attendait pas du magnétomètre bout de
la perche de filet
il sert à mesurer le champ magnétique
mais il renvoie aussi des signaux sur
ses mouvements par rapport au sol et
sous la base des des anomalies des ces
signaux on a vu qu'il a égaré quelque
chose l'élément cette belge avec push
est bouché l'obstacle année donc comme
ça ces signaux vont permettre
d'identifier la durée de l'impact entre
phil hay et la surface en question ont
une odeur trois secondes site où on le
voit juste ici aussi peu de temps pour
compresser la glace de 25 cm
c'est un signe que la matière est
vraiment mal en fait ce mélange de glace
d'eau et de matière sombre à la surface
de la comète est rempli une porosité
estimer à 75%
quelque chose qui ressemble vraiment la
neige tombée données sensation de
légèreté il doit y avoir sur la comète
cette information inespéré s'ajoute à
toutes les autres données qui ont été
recueillis elles permettent de mieux
comprendre la composition des comètes en
vue des prochaines exploration ambitieux
dans sa chute chaotique fils a et aura
malgré lui permis d'étudier trois sites
plutôt qu'un seul
et de révéler des secrets de la comète
souris qu'on croyait enfoui à jamais